donc nos quatre parlementaires nous ont
rejoint donc je vais le demander mais
ils ont l'habitude de faire ça très bien
c'est à dire d'être concis clair rapide
pour présenter la vingtaine petite
vingtaine de propositions que l'on fait
ils vont le présenter rapidement après
donc l'introduction par christiane et
puis ensuite on se tournera à nouveau
vers christiane lambert pour lui poser
un certain nombre de questions et
relayer les questions nos internautes
alors qu'ils commencent vous avez
préparé un ordre
allez laurent duplomb donc sénateur de
haute loire est par ailleurs producteur
de lait tout à fait merci christian
d'abord bonjour à christiane bonjour à
toutes et à tous donc moi je suis chargé
de vous présenter une partie de notre
convention qui correspond à ce que aussi
a dit christiane et avant de rentrer
dans le détail je voudrais vous
remercier monsieur savoie pour pour les
propos qu'il a tenus parce que d'abord
comme l'a dit christian en étalant
l'agriculteur je suis touché toujours
dans la possibilité des mots qui font
que lorsqu'on dit que l'agriculture en
france était une bonne agriculture est
qu'elle permet de sublimer dans la
gastronomie des produits c'est d'abord
rendre au respect et remerciements à
tous ceux qui se lèvent tous les matins
pour faire ce travail qui est difficile
de l'agriculture et c'est une forme de
reconnaissance qui me veulent non
seulement droit au corps mais qui je le
sais respecte et met en évidence le
labeur de tous ces agriculteurs qui font
la beauté de la france et la beauté de
notre gastronomie
voilà cette introduction en fait la
partie dont je dois vous rapportez
correspond à ceux aussi ce qu'a dit
christiane c'est renforcer notre
compétitivité par rapport à notre
culture
le constat est simple nous l'avons écrit
et ça me permet de saluer la président
de la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat se fit prima j'ai
écrit un rapport en 2019 au nom de la
commission des affaires économiques qui
démontrait que la france cette grande
france agricole
on a tant vu être au rendez-vous de la
nourriture depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale et bien aujourd'hui est dans
une situation difficile
dans le fait ou la balance commerciale
deviendrait à notre avis totalement
déficitaire à partir de 2023 puisque
nous perdons tous les jours départ de
compétitivité sur nos différentes
filières à nos différents produits donc
un des éléments le plus important dans
cette convention à nous c'est de dire
très clairement qu'il faut que nous
regagnons des éléments qui permettent de
stopper cette hémorragie et de retrouver
des formes de compétitivité cette
compétitivité elle est difficile à
gagner parce que plein d'éléments
viennent aujourd'hui contrecarrer notre
capacité de production
ça passe par des problématiques
normative des problématiques de
contraintes mais aussi de trouver des
solutions pour améliorer comme la diro
sylla président de la fnsea
notre compétitivité par exemple à
travers l'emploi quatre grandes
propositions quatre grands chapitres ont
été établies le premier s'est instauré
le principe entre guillemets pas
d'interdiction sans solution on ne peut
plus continuer d'avoir des injonctions
contradictoires entre le fait
d'interdire un produit et en sachant
pertinemment qu'on met la filière
française qui est lié à cette production
dans l'impasse on ne peut plus continuer
comme ça nous l'avons vu malheureusement
sur plusieurs exemples l'exemple des nox
néonicotinoïdes en est un l'exemple dit
que les choses at demain pour en être un
autre et donc on se doit de rentrer dans
un système qui préserve notre intérêt
national en terme agricoles qui devrait
être dans le sens de dire toutes les
solutions une fois qu'elles ne sont pas
trouvés elles ne peuvent pas engendré
par le principe des décisions que nous
prenons des interdictions
supplémentaires donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui nous semble extrêmement
important est que nous avons voulu
mettre en évidence
la deuxième proposition c'est
d'interdire la sueur transposition des
normes
quand je parle de sueur transposition
des normes ce et des problématiques
européennes c'est-à-dire des normes
françaises qui sont en plus les normes
européennes
mais j'aurais envie de dire aussi des
règles que nous imposons purement en
france quand sur la loi et galim dans le
titre de
nous interdisons les remises rabais et
ristournes sur les produits
phytosanitaires
nous tuons une partie de la
compétitivité des agriculteurs français
qui ne peuvent plus négocier leurs
produits alors que d'autres agriculteurs
qui viennent les concurrencer d'autres
pays continuent d'avoir ces mêmes
ristournes rabais et remises
il faut que cette sueur transposition
elle soit limité de façon à ce que nous
ne tombions pas dans ce système constant
constant de se tirer des balles dans le
pied
le troisième élément est l'interdiction
d'importer en europe des produits qui ne
respectent pas nos normes
je viens encore d'établir pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière au nom de la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat un rapport sur la problématique du
sénat origines inde avec 3700 à 5000
fois la dose d'oxydé d'éthylène
autorisée en france parce que tout
simplement nous avons une certaine forme
de naïveté au niveau des autorités
à croire que parce que nous interdisons
un produit chez nous il n'est plus
utilisé dans d'autres pays et surtout il
ne revient pas à travers nos
importations par dans nos assiettes
et donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
que nous mettions fin là dessus enfin
sur deux principes d'abord sur le
contrôle des produits à l'intérieur de
notre pays au niveau européen de façon à
faire respecter les mesures que nous
mettons en place d'abord par souci de
respect du consommateur mais aussi par
souci de respect des producteurs
auxquels nous imposons des contraintes
supplémentaires qui demande souvent des
coûts supplémentaires qui font qu'on est
sur une concurrence totalement déloyale
quand nous ne contrôlons pas les
produits qui viennent les concurrencer
et qui ne respectent pas ces nobles
le deuxième élément c'est qu'il faut
aussi poussé ces éléments de réflexion
aussi sur les contrats sur les accords
de libre échange
nous ne pouvons pas être là aussi dans
une stature de total naïveté quand dans
un compte dans un accord de libre
échange
nous garantissons aux consommateurs et
aux producteurs qui seront concurrencés
par des produits que nous acceptons de
faire rentrer sur notre territoire
parce que tout simplement d'en traiter
nous aurons écrit qu'il est interdit de
s'en donner les moyens de contrôler si
cet index cette interdiction est
totalement respectée et donc nous ne
pouvons plus continuer comme ça et nous
estimons que là dessus il faut
signé la fin de la mi temps le quatrième
élément est le dernier pour ma part
c'est de pérenniser comme l'a dit
christiane le dispositif d'exonération
des cotisations patronales appelé
vulgairement dans le milieu agricole le
thé au 2e je pense que ça va au delà de
cela quand on regarde et quand on se
compare la france coûte 1,5 fois plus
cher en terme de main d'oeuvre que
l'allemagne 1,7 fois plus cher que
l'espagne est plus de deux fois plus
cher que des travailleurs dans les pays
de l'est ce qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
quand on veut regagner de la
compétitivité
eh bien il faut regarder ces éléments en
face et trouver des solutions soit par
des exonérations de charges patronales
soit par une vraie politique nationale
qui viendrait diminuer le coût du
travail en france de façon à retrouver
départ de compétitivité qui permettront
à nos produits de garder le devant de la
scène sur le marché français et
vis-à-vis des consommateurs d'avoir là
un prix de revient de nos produits qui
correspondent à d'autres produits qui
viennent les concurrencer et qui sont
produits sur d'autres pays voisins
parfois ou sur d'autres continents
voilà christian les quelques éléments
que j'avais à vous présenter et en
tenant son temps bravo alors après city
c'est valérie c'est anne qui est anne
and sand air donc qui est député
européen et qui suit pour les
républicains notamment le le budget
agricole au parlement européen et les
questions agricoles de manière plus
large mais le budget c'est un vrai sujet
en soi
am merci christian et bonsoir à tous je
suis moi aussi très heureuse d'être là
pour évoquer l'agriculture
l'alimentation française est évidemment
européenne je suis pour ma part chargé
de vous parler de la sécurité
alimentaire c'est un vrai défi la
sécurité alimentaire pendant des années
lorsqu'on parlait de sécurité on avait
plutôt tendance à penser aux politiques
liées à l'intérieur à la défense à
l'économie à la cybersécurité aussi mais
c'est vrai que très souvent et bien au
nommé t on ne pensait pas eh bien la
sécurité alimentaire voire
l'alimentation l'agriculture comme une
véritable arme à détenir et
à défendre donc c'est un vrai défi que
nous avons aujourd'hui devant nous et
quand on dit sécurité alimentaire eh
bien nous pensons à la quantité
nous raisonnons aussi en termes de
qualité et évidemment il faut penser à
l'accessibilité en termes de prix parce
que tous nos concitoyens et bien ne sont
pas logés à la même enseigne donc
évidemment nous voulons tous faire
monter notre agriculture en qualité mais
derrière il faut être conscient que
cette alimentation cette agriculture et
bien doit rester accessible
alors je vais pour ma part vous
présenter trois propositions très
concrètes
une première proposition en partant et
bien deux constats comme ça a été dit
que la population mondiale va augmenter
il y a une volonté de plus en plus
importante de baisser le nombre
d'intrants c'est d'ailleurs aussi ce qui
est prévu au niveau européen avec le
pacte vert avec la stratégie de la ferme
à la fourchette avec la stratégie
biodiversité
donc nous voulons baisser le nombre d'un
trois les surfaces cultivées et bien là
aussi on prévoit qu'elle diminue dans
les prochaines années
alors pour nourrir la population la
population française la population
mondiale
eh bien nous devons miser sur la
recherche sur la recherche sur
l'innovation
donc nous devons mieux produire et là il
ya toute une palette de produits à
développer il faut il ya tout un travail
qui doit être fait sur des nouvelles
techniques
je pense par exemple aux technologies
issues de la mutagénèse qui doivent bien
être distingués des ogm c'est un débat
que nous devons avoir au niveau européen
et c'est un débat que nous devons
aborder de manière non pas passionnel
mais vraiment en se reposant sur les
connaissances scientifiques là aussi il
ya tout un travail à faire pour
valoriser ce travail scientifique
nous devons
investir dans la recherche dans
l'innovation pour la sélection variétale
nous devons aussi développer
l'agriculture de précision et pour cela
il nous faut des vrais budgets
enfin je dirais que il faut surtout une
des financements pour la recherche
publique en agriculture et en
particulier en réorientant les
financements et les missions de l'inra
eux sur la recherche agronomique et
variétale deuxième proposition sur
laquelle nous avons travaillé c'est
évidemment le la politique agricole
commune
vous savez qu'au niveau européen eh bien
nous avons lancé un pacte vert qui va
concerner toutes les politiques
que ce soit les transports que ce soit
l'industrie if le logement tout le monde
sera concerné est évidemment
l'agriculture elle aussi est bien va y
contribuer alors pour cela évidemment il
faut accompagner les agriculteurs dans
cette transition d'agriculteurs qui ont
d'ailleurs fait déjà beaucoup d'efforts
pour produire mieux en respectant mieux
l'environnement
donc cette transition elle doit être
accompagnée elle doit être susciter et
on doit être dans une logique punitif et
pour cela il faut un budget de la
politique agricole commune et bien
qu'ils soient à la hauteur de nos
ambitions
or aujourd'hui est bien le budget qui a
été négocié par les états membres
alors c'est vrai que nous revenons de
loin sur ce sur ce budget mais néanmoins
il est à la baisse par rapport à la à la
période précédente donc c'est un vrai
travail à faire au niveau européen et
les républicains ont toujours été
constant dans leur démarche en
maintenant en demandant le maintien du
budget de la pac il y à la question du
budget de la pac mais il ya aussi le
maintien du caractère commun de la
politique agricole commune
là où certains seraient tentés de
détricoter la politique agricole commune
de la relation
l'idée est bien tout notre combat c'est
de la garder commune
nous voulons pas comme une non pas
uniforme parce qu'évidemment il faut
tenir compte des réalités de nos
territoires
même en france nous avons une multitude
d'agriculture en europe c'est le cas
aussi donc on tient compte des
spécificités mais il faut un cadre
commun fort pour éviter une distorsion
de concurrence dont seraient victimes
nos agriculteurs français qui sont déjà
victimes de beaucoup plus de sueur
transposition que leurs collègues dans
d'autres pays européens
nous parlons beaucoup des fameuses échos
régime ce sont des mesures qui vont
pousser les agricultures les
agriculteurs à produire à faire plus
d'efforts encore alors aujourd'hui il
est question d'un pourcentage des coûts
régime
moi ce qui m'inquiète aussi c'est ce
qu'on va mettre quelles sont les mesures
qui seront mises dans ces éco régime
elles doivent permettre aux agriculteurs
d'accéder à ces mesures mais surtout
nous devons avoir la même ambition
partout en europe
et puis la 7e lallaoui la 7e proposition
que je voudrais vous présenter
eh bien elle porte sur le revenu des
agriculteurs et sur la manière de lutter
contre la volatilité des prix des
matières premières en mettant en place
en place un filet de sécurité
financé par des fonds européens je crois
que nous devons revenir aux fondamentaux
de la pac stabiliser les marchés mais
aussi assurer un revenu à nos
agriculteurs parce que son revenu pas
d'agriculture pas d'environnement là
aussi il nous faut des moyens pour cela
et bien nous nous battons pour réviser
la réserve de crise au niveau européen
pour faire en sorte d'accumuler des
financements il nous faut aussi des
outils des outils d'intervention des
outils d'intervention sur les marchés
agricoles s'éteint c'est un vrai sujet
c'est ce que nous négocions actuellement
dans le cadre de la réforme de la de la
politique
agricole commune je voudrais dire aussi
que le produit de la cap taxe carbone
aux frontières européennes qui en train
d'être discutés qui sera pas facile à
mettre en oeuvre mais que nous avons
toujours défendu et bien pourrait
financer en partie ses dispositifs et
puis dernier point la gestion des
risques christiane en a parlé c'est un
vrai défi
alors on l'abord de manière timorée dans
dans le 2e pilier de la politique
agricole commune mais évidemment nous
devons aller beaucoup plus loin et c'est
une proposition forte soutenue par les
républicains merci merci anne
on continue avec les propositions c'est
si julien donc on est passé du sénat au
parlement européen on revient à
l'assemblée nationale avec julien dive
keanu spécialiste des questions
agricoles
merci et merci christian merci à tous et
à tous je voudrais en profiter
dans ce temps de transition pour aussi
remercier tous nos collègues qui ont
participé pendant 15 mois au sein du
forum numéro 5 agriculture et
alimentation
il ya des agriculteurs il ya des élus
locaux des maires d un président de
conseil départemental et c'est vrai que
c'est un travail collectif qui nous a
permis de mener un certain nombre
d'auditions qui nous ont par la suite
amené à c'est à ces différentes
propositions et je tenais à le rappeler
pour pour pour nos spectateurs qui nous
suivent
alors oui on a un d un des axes qu'on
souhaitait défendre dans nos
propositions c'est la sécurisation de
notre production agricole nationale
on parlait tout à l'heure de
souveraineté nationale c'est un terme
qui est devenue quelque part à la mode
depuis confinement successifs puisque
avec le confirme en quelque part les
comportements des consommateurs ont
évolué avec leur tour quelque part à la
ferme à l'artisan du coin ou encore
redécouvrir certains producteurs locaux
la question des souverainetés d'accord
c'est essentiel et en même temps pour
nous tous c'est aussi de rappeler à quel
point la france a une chance d'avoir une
culture aussi forte
au lendemain des deux guerres mondiales
successives
on a su faire de nous de nos campagnes d
terreau propice justement au
développement de l'agriculture et d'en
faire une force
à l'euro l'échelle européenne mais aussi
à l'international girac par les deux
puissances verte et c'est pas un hasard
alors en parlant de notre souveraineté
en parlant de notre force
eh bien il faut pas non plus interdire
d'être plus bête que la moyenne et on
sait très bien qu'en france on a des
standards on a des standards des
réglementations des lois on parlait tout
à l'heure d'interdire lé sud et sur
transposition on sait que la france est
beaucoup plus sévère que beaucoup de
pays voisins que beaucoup de pays dont
nous importons des produits alimentaires
cela veut dire m appelle à dire surtout
que nous devons avoir confiance que nos
citoyens doivent avoir confiance en
notre culture en l'alimentation produits
ricol qui sont dans nos dans nos dans
nos campagnes qui sont développées chez
nos éleveurs qui sont produits dans nos
champs
tout ça pour dire que il est important
pour nous de savoir défendre notre
production agricole nationale et nous
avons voulu au travers de nos
propositions aura le rappeler est aussi
mettre en avant
un phénomène qui est qui et pourtant
mais le paradoxe quelque part de ces
situations c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs et bien font face à un
certain nombre de difficultés
la question de la rémunération nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure christiane lors
du temps des changes avec les questions
de nos internautes
la question aussi du renouvellement des
générations et j'en parlerai tout à
l'heure avec les propositions que nous
avons formulées ou encore des questions
techniques que nous nous interdisons
comme par exemple le stockage de l'eau
alors j'en viens à la première
proposition que nous avons voulu
formuler au travers de ce travail c'est
celle d'augmenter significativement la
part de production nationale dans les
marchés publics
pourquoi eh bien on n'a pas réellement
de données précises sur la part de
produits importés dans la restauration
collective publique les cantines etc
par contre on a une tendance on sait
qu'en dehors du domicile et bien 70% des
produits enfin 70% des poulets pardon
consommé dans la restauration sont
importés par exemple 40% des ports qui
sont consommés en dehors de la maison
sont aussi importer ce qui donne quand
même une tendance sur l'importation de
produits alimentaires au sein même de
nos cantines scolaires et nous ce que
nous proposons c'est de faciliter de
renforcer ce lien fort entre nos
producteurs entre
nous nous continuons de scolaires entre
les cantines collectives des
collectivités publiques en permettant de
modifier quelque part le code des
marchés publics
ça fait que c'est un certain nombre de
critères qui permettent de noter et
d'attribuer un marché plus qu'à bien en
modifiant le code des marchés publics
pour donner une vraie plus-value une
vraie chance à nos producteurs d'être
d'être retenu et d'avoir un débouché
complémentaires parlant de production
nationale et bien évidemment on parle de
débouchés il ya aussi la question de
l'approvisionnement
tous nos concitoyens ne
s'approvisionnent pas celle artisans du
coin ou à la ferme mais il ya
incontournable c'est la grande
distribution nous ont aussi l'occasion
d'en débattre tout à l'heure avec un de
nos invités et nous ce que nous voulons
même s'il ya des efforts qui ont été
portés dans plusieurs chez plusieurs
acteurs de la grande distribution en
nouant des partenariats avec certains
producteurs nous ce que nous voulons au
travers de la seconde la deuxième
proposition est bien c'est de mettre en
place un système de référence de
référencement beaucoup plus rapides
beaucoup plus un fip simplifiée entre
les producteurs locaux et les grandes
surfaces et je pense notamment en
évitant par exemple de passer en étant
obligé de passer par des centrales
d'achat de faciliter le lien au plus
près entre celui qui distribue qui amène
un an l'ensemble de nos consommateurs et
bien tout un tas de produits
alimentaires et en identifiant ceux qui
sont locaux l'une de l'une de nos
problématiques à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés à laquelle notre production
de l'école est confronté je l' ai dit en
introduction c'est la question du
renouvellement des générations dans les
cinq années qui viennent 40 % des
exploitants agricoles partiront en
retraite
pour cela nous voulons inciter et c'est
des propositions qui sont formulées
notamment par les jeunes agriculteurs
dans l'épreuve dans les recueils qui ne
recueille qui me l'ont transmis
récemment c'est d'inciter la
transmission des exploitations aux
jeunes agriculteurs à ceux qui veulent
s'installer tout simplement en mettant
en place des mécanismes vous savez
l'enjeu c'est de pouvoir vivre de son
travail qui aujourd'hui souhaite monter
une entreprise qui ne dégage pas de
marche qui ne gâche pas de revenus il
faut qu'on puisse permettre de donner à
ces jeunes agriculteurs de vivre du
produit de leur travail est bien en
en place des mécanismes comme par
exemple une incitation fiscale déduction
fiscale des résultats ou encore des
accompagnements techniques d
accompagnement financier d
accompagnement humain tout simplement
parce que le monde change les habitudes
de consommation je le disais change
l'agriculture changer une transition
agricole qui est en mouvement avec des
démesures et ddd système cultural qui
évolue qui sont différents d'un
territoire à l'autre et il est aussi
important d'accompagner nos jeunes en
parlant de l'accompagnement des jeunes
c'est aussi communiquer au mieux et ça
c'est une proposition qu'on a aussi
voulu formuler communiquer au mieux sur
les métiers qu'il y a dans l'agriculture
christiane combien de main d'oeuvre
avons nous besoin dans notre culture
chaque année je me souviens d'un appel
que vous aviez fait l'an dernier au
plein coeur du confinement où il y avait
des besoins de main d'oeuvre pour
récolter je n'étais pas 300 milles ou je
ne sais plus le chiffre c'est quelque
chose d'assez colossal 700 milles c'est
pire que tout le territoire national
il y à valoriser les métiers
d'agriculture est exploitant mais il ya
aussi tout un tas de métiers dans dans
ces filières là qu'il faut pouvoir se
réapproprier
il y à une un débouché et on pourra pas
faire de notre culture une force si on
n'a pas la main les mains d'oeuvre si on
n'a pas les hommes les femmes prêtes à
se retrousser les manches pour faire vu
notre agriculture
et puis je disais en introduction qu'il
ya des questions de technique qu'on a
voulu aussi abordée je disais de manière
un peu caricaturale on peut pas ça on va
pas s'interdire non plus d'être plus
bête que la moyenne et c'est vrai que
quand on compare à certains pays où la
pluviométrie est beaucoup plus faible
qu'en france je pense à l'espagne
il y a des outils il y à des démarches
qui sont engagés par ces pays là pour
stocker l'eau allemagne l'espagne pardon
stocker plus de 20% de l'eau qui tombe
pour à la fois éviter de les puiser dans
les nappes pour permettre des meilleure
irrigation pour aussi lutter contre les
inondations union en france on capte 4%
qu'un peu plus de 4% 2 de notre de l'eau
qui tombe la pluie de la pluviométrie
que nous avons sur notre sol national
beaucoup de pays ont fait ces efforts là
le danemark landry sont partis dans
cette dynamique nous
pensons qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin en améliorant la gestion du
stockage de l'eau en peut-être en
supprimant les freins administratifs qui
existent aujourd'hui en révolutionnant
aussi un peu les préjugés qu'il ya sur
ces questions là et puis on a aussi
voulu
puisqu'on parle quelque part du stockage
l'eau c'est aussi faire référence est
fait l écho aux aléas climatiques
on a voulu aussi aller plus loin en
rendant l'assurance récolte beaucoup
plus attractive en élargissant
finalement la possibilité à tous les
acteurs de l'assurance de pouvoir
s'engager dans cette dynamique je pense
avoir été assez succinct pour passer la
parole à ma collègue valérie bodin magra
merci merci julien parole valérie donc
valérie qui est député de l'aube qui
travaillent au sein de l'équipe
dirigeante des républicains sur les
sujets du commerce most hid de
l'agriculture parce que
professionnellement elle était plutôt
dans les arts de la table donc elle
n'est pas très éloigné du monde de
l'alimentation exactement merci mon cher
christian chers collègues
bonsoir à vous tous qui nous regarde et
je voudrais moi aussi remercié le nombre
d'experts par exemple de mon département
qui se sont joints aux travaux et qui
nous ont fait progresser juste pour
toutes ces propositions on va vous
exposer et tu le disais christian c'est
vrai que je viens du monde de
l'industrie et du commerce mais je suis
très sensible au monde de l'agriculture
venant d'un territoire très rurale
l'aube
donc je suis vraiment toujours partie
prenante lorsqu'il faut que
l'agriculture donc la partie qui
m'incombe ce soir de vous présenter ses
respectés l'acte de production et de
transformation parce que nous avons
constaté que la relation déséquilibrée
qui pèse sur les négociations
commerciales des tarifs entre la grande
distribution et les agriculteurs
constituent évidemment et tout le monde
le sait une énorme difficulté pour la
rémunération des agriculteurs
il est nécessaire de rééquilibrer cette
relation et de contrôler et voire même
de sanctionner ceux qui auraient des
pratiques abusives donc c'est tout un
tas de propositions que nous allons vous
faire justement pour faire améliorer
tout ça mais aussi l'agriculture peut
être une solution pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
tic et préserver les ressources
naturelles et la biodiversité
elle est à la fois l'agriculture victime
causes et solutions de la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique
or nous devons faire le défi de ce défi
climatique une réelle opportunité pour
l'agriculture donc avant de commencer la
première proposition que j'ai à vous
exposer
je voulais simplement vous poser un peu
le décor est vous dire que la principale
difficulté pour nos agriculteurs c'est
de vendre leurs produits à leur coût de
revient afin qu'ils en tirent des marges
pour vivre correctement de leur travail
sa part être le b à ba dans chaque
profession mais malheureusement on le
sait et on constate les agriculteurs ne
vivent pas suffisamment bien de leur
travail leur rémunération moyenne est de
15000 euros par an soit 1250 euros par
mois on sait que malheureusement et
c'est un scandale à un tiers des
agriculteurs vivent avec seulement 350
euros par mois que 22% des agriculteurs
sont sous lé seuil de pauvreté
et on sait également que vingt-deux
mille familles d'agriculteurs font appel
aux airs et a donc tout ça ce n'est pas
entendable et la proposition la première
proposition que nous faisons c'est que
l'achat de produits agricoles doit
respecter le prix couvrant le coût de
production sur toute la chaîne
d'approvisionnement sous peine de
sanctions donc les interprofessions
devront définir et publier ses coûts de
production de référence
il faut que ça devienne une référence
révisable évidemment en fonction de
l'évolution des prix des matières
premières agricoles sous l'autorité du
ministère de l'agriculture
cette proposition a deux objectifs
d'abord de mentionner ce principe dans
la loi on sait que dans la loi on n'a
pas le droit de vendre des prix à de
vendre des produits agricoles à des prix
abusivement bas mais malheureusement il
n'est pas indiqué justement c'est ses
coûts de production minimum il n'est pas
indiqué qu'on doive y faire référence
donc on veut inscrire sa dans la loi et
deuxièmement il faut inciter toutes les
interprofessions à élaborer justement
est publié
ces indicateurs de coûts de production
pour avoir une référence d'achat de ces
prix de produits agricoles
on sait également que le tarif des
matières agricoles est au plus bas
depuis des milliers 2018 qu'il existe
évidemment des distorsions de
concurrence avec les autres pays qui
exportent en france et produit bien
moins cher que les nôtres donc comment
voulez vous que les agriculteurs s'y
retrouvent c'est absolument impossible
on sait également que l'acte de
production n'est pas respectée en france
il faut faire évoluer tout ça d'où cette
proposition et on sait aussi que la loi
et galim ne permet pas pour le mans
d'atteindre l'objectif de revalorisation
des salaires des revenus qui était prévu
dans cette loi donc malheureusement
voilà une belle loi qui n'a pas fait
avancer grand chose pour le moment nous
l'a passée à la deuxième proposition à
pouvoir poser à la création d'une
centrale d'achat je pense qu'on s'est
laissé inconvénients du direct on va
changer de micros voilà très bien
mercian l'état a le pouvoir de s'opposer
à la création d'une centrale d'achats
qui dépasse le seuil de 15% de parts de
marché au niveau européen ce ça y est
fixé par la commission européenne et
l'état a le pouvoir mais n'a pas les
moyens d'exercer son rôle de contrôle
donc nous proposons de renforcer
significativement les moyens de la
direction générale de la concurrence de
la consommation et de la répression des
fraudes et de permettre à l'autorité de
la concurrence de s'opposer à la
création d'une centrale d'achat
lorsqu'elles dépassent un seuil de parts
de marché défini au niveau européen
on sait par ailleurs que les ministères
regorge de fonctionnaires qu'il y en a
beaucoup sur notre territoire mais
malheureusement sur un total de 140
agents à la dgccrf seulement 13 d'entre
eux sont affectés aux bureaux commerces
pour contrôler justement ces relations
qu'aux fins commerciales donc ce n'est
pas suffisant on demande et on propose
justement de muscler la dgccrf afin
qu'il y ait des contrôles encore une
fois pour que nos agriculteurs puissent
vendre leurs produits minimum aux coûts
de production mais voir plus bien sûr
pour qu'il réussisse à gagner leur vie
correctement
et il est nécessaire également
d'augmenter les moyens humains et
financiers consacrés aux enquêtes et
contrôles pour lutter contre ces
pratiques illégales
voilà la proposition suivante que j'ai à
vous exposer ses rémunérer les
producteurs qui améliore le stockage du
carbone dans le sol on sait que
l'agriculture évolué nous avons
d'ailleurs pendant nos travaux visiter
une ferme qui fait d'agriculture de
conservation et de l'agriculture de
conservation des sols et cette pratique
nous savons permettent de stocker du
carbone dans le sol et la législation
doit évoluer afin de rémunérer les
producteurs qui améliore le stockage du
carbone dans les sols
c'est donc une proposition que nous
allons également défendre et soutenir
nous devons faire donc du défi
climatique une réelle opportunité pour
l'agriculture est une source de
rémunération pour nos agriculteurs
il faut inciter les entreprises dans le
cadre des contrats de prestations de
services environnementaux
environnementaux pardon les contrats de
droit privé entre agriculteurs et
entreprises au titre de la rse et la
doctrine éviter réduire compenser à
pratiquer la compensation sur le sol
national
voilà je vous remercie pour mes
propositions j'en ai terminé merci merci
valérie alors on va passer à la partie
débat qui n'en avait encore trois autres
qui est ce qu'il est présente c'est
julien s'est tous les trois mais je
vends vas-y du jeu commence par la
première en fait on a aussi
effectivement dans le dernier paragraphe
dédié justement à nos propositions
on a voulu avoir un thème dédié à
l'information des citoyens en s'appuyant
notamment sur les données scientifiques
et c'est une des premières propositions
qu'on fait c'est vrai que je t'aime moi
non plus c'est comme ça je résoudrai
quelque part le rapport de la société
des citoyens avec la science pourtant la
science répond aux besoins de la société
la franc la science répond aux enjeux
mondiaux défis mondiaux et on a un
sentiment ces dernières années que la
science est un peu écarté de beaucoup de
débats
est ce qu'on a voulu c'est que l'action
soit replacé au coeur des débats
démocratiques tout à l'heure en parler
dans une de nos propositions formulées
par laurent 2
deux n 2 comment dire pas d'interdiction
sans solution et bien c'est quelque part
ce fait qu ce lien fort qu'à la science
on note de plus en plus le poids à
certaines associations de plus en plus
de poids aux à ce qu'on appelle les
lanceurs dallaire sur les réseaux
sociaux de plus en plus de poids aux ong
dans les débats démocratiques de moins
en moins à la science pour autant il ya
des instituts scientifiques indépendants
qui ont qui ont un travail depuis des
décennies qui ont apporté des réponses
aux défis qui sont les nôtres qui ont
jamais été contestée et on ordonne plus
est ce temps fort donc que nous
souhaitons dans nos propositions
c'est de redonner du corps et de la
place à la science dans les débats
démocratiques
merci alors après on enchaîne on
accélère pour avoir appris dans des bars
avec une de nos propositions merci
christian cet encadré les applications
numériques sur l'alimentation par des
lignes directrices définies par l'état
parce que vous savez bien tous les
consommateurs maintenant dans leurs
smartphones des applications qui
permettent de tester les produits
donc il ya tout et rien dans ce genre
d'applications et nous demandons
justement de les encadrer et de les
améliorer
alors pour moi la dernière proposition
la 18e et je voudrais rappeler moi aussi
que l'ensemble de ces propositions
émanent de travaux que nous avons eues
avec des experts ils ont été cités avec
des élus locaux mais aussi avec des
militants des citoyens qui se sont
engagés et sur cette dernière
proposition s'adresse vraiment aux
consommateurs à la population et il
s'agit d'imposer un étiquetage de
l'origine claire et harmonisée au niveau
européen sur tous les produits
alimentaires réservé aussi la mention
origine france au seul produit dont la
matière première brute a été produite en
france et dont l'ensemble des
transformations substantiels ont été
réalisés sur le territoire français je
crois que c'est très important parce que
eh bien nos concitoyens demandent des
informations sur les modes de production
mais en même temps il ya tellement
d'étiquetage différent que ce soit le
nutritionnel que ce soit sur l'origine
donc il faut vraiment que nous puissions
avoir cet étiquetage clair merci